يوجد في تايلاند أكثر من 40 ألف
معبد بوذي ، لكن هناك واحدًا
فقط يبدو تمامًا مثل هذا اكتمل في عام
2004 وات بلايا إم عبارة عن مجموعة من
المعابد والتماثيل الموجودة في ثاني أكبر جزيرة في كوه ساموي في
تايلاند ، وهي
معابد نشطة في مكان هادئ حيث
انعكاس هادئ  يُشجع على
ارتداء الملابس المناسبة ، وهو
أحد أكثر الشخصيات التي تلفت الأنظار
هو تمثال بوذا الذي يبلغ ارتفاعه 30
مترًا والمرسوم باللون الأحمر الفاتح
والأبيض
والذهبي ، والتمثال الرئيسي في Wat pile Am هي
إلهة الرحمة والرحمة البوذية
غوان يي هنا ممثلة بـ 18
ذراعًا مما يدل على قدرتها على مساعدة
العديد من الأشخاص المحتاجين في الحال ، المعبد
محاط ببحيرة مليئة
بالأسماك الجائعة ،
يتم إعطاء الزائرين الذين يتبرعون للمعبد كيسًا من فواكه الأسماك ،
كما يشتري الناس الأسماك أيضًا  والسلاحف
في سوق الطعام المحلي
وإطلاقها في البحيرة ، يعتبر البوذيون أن
ذلك عمل من أعمال الجدارة الروحية
والأسماك والسلاحف تفعل ذلك أيضًا
[تصفيق]